comenzó el 2023 y Colombia y Venezuela
inauguraron el puente atanasio girardot
este estaba listo para ser transitado
desde hace más de seis años delegaciones
de ambos países celebraron el hito
de prosperidad para ambas naciones para
Colombia y para Venezuela y muy
especialmente para la zona de frontera
estamos haciendo bala a la paz y hoy se
hace en este puente atanasio girardot se
hace gala de una apertura de nuestras
vidas el 26 de septiembre fueron
reabiertos los dos principales puentes
internacionales que comunican el
departamento del norte de Santander en
Colombia y táchira en Venezuela con este
inicio de año ha sido el turno también
sobre el río táchira de latanasio
girardot todavía quedará pendiente la
reapertura del puente José Antonio Páez
ubicado entre araucayapure el atanasio
girardot se construyó para
descongestionar el Simón Bolívar y el
Francisco de Paula Santander por los que
circula 30.000 vehículos diarios las
obras acabaron en 2016 pero en ese
momento el presidente de Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro ya había cerrado la
frontera por tensiones con el gobierno
de Juan Manuel Santos este fue el
antecedente a la ruptura definitiva de
las relaciones en 2019 cuando el
entonces presidente Iván Duque reconoció
a Juan guaidó como su homólogo y
calificó al gobierno venezolano de
Dictadura la llegada de Gustavo Petro al
poder en Colombia en agosto de 2022 ha
traído consigo la reanudación de
relaciones diplomáticas y de una
frontera que en su mejor momento alcanzó
el intercambio comercial de 7.000
millones de dólares en 2020 cayó a 220
millones de dólares Pero entre enero y
octubre de 2022 ya se recuperó hasta los
512 millones de dólares